what's the difference between a script
analyst a script consultant and a script
doctor oh I love that question because
it always comes up and people tend to
get confused with a three but I always
say it goes sort of in stages so script
analyst you graduate to script
consultant and then you graduate to
scriptdoctor so the script analyst will
be the way you would start in the
business if this is what you want to do
you know you want to work in development
or something like that well maybe even
before that you would be an intern or
something you know just like reading
scripts providing coverage a lot of
times unpaid you know for different
agencies or things like that and that's
when you start you know polishing and
honing your skills reading but after
that you would start maybe hopefully
getting paid to read those scripts and
that's what
would make you a script analyst you know
that's the way I got started in the
business I started interning and then I
got promoted to script analysts and I
would just read hundreds of scripts a
year and provide like simple coverage
you know to producers or agents whoever
you're working for uh because obviously
they can't read all of the scripts that
come to their desk right so you would
read their scripts then give like
overall notes uh whether this is working
or not what could be improved if there's
the seat of an idea there because
sometimes you know you're also looking
for that and then they might hire
another writer to improve the script so
you're trying to look for different
things like that depending on who you're
working for
um and then uh once you know you've been
working on it for a while and then you
realize oh I'm actually good at this you
know like I can give notes and I can
start working maybe in that path then
you could graduate to script consultant
as I would call it and then you'd start
giving more in-depth notes so for
example I like to call it like in death
notes more than just script analysis at
that stage when you're a script
consultant because you're not just
giving like the overall notes you're not
just analyzing if a script is working or
not maybe here and there but you're
going deeper so
um I always say that you should provide
development notes and Page notes which
are equally important to me development
notes is where you're analyzing all
aspects of the script right like uh the
structure the dialogue the characters
how the arcs are working the turning
points everything and then page notes
are equally important because they're
things that you're noticing literally on
the page and you start marking down
maybe something that doesn't track or
something that contradicts something
that you said or something that you
missed or a character that just happens
to appear and it wasn't set up or
something like that so those two things
kind of complement each other
and the script consultant uh depending
on who they're working for right
sometimes they're working for a producer
or sometimes they're working directly
with the writer they would provide those
notes and then the writer would
implement the notes hopefully in the
script if the library if they agree with
them or something obviously it's never
just like apply that exact no note I
always give suggestions as I call it
because I think that it's the node
behind the node a lot of times and I'm
never trying to tell my story when I
give notes like that it's the way to
elevate The Writer's story
and I'd like impose my thoughts and then
after you've been working as a script
consultant for a while then I say you
graduate to scriptdoctor which is a step
further there where you also implement
the notes that you're suggesting and it
goes a little further than that uh
because you sort of work with the writer
or the producer whoever is hiring you to
do it uh to find the best way to
continue telling that story and
remaining true to the essence of what
the story is you know and elevating
maybe sometimes it's just one area you
know maybe it's a dialogue pass or maybe
is the protagonist Arc that is just not
clear enough or something like that so
you're working on polishing that
but I always say that for example I
provide the notes you know like the
development notes the page notes but
then I like to have a one-on-one
conversation with whoever I'm working so
we can agree on a course of action
because again I don't like to say like
oh this is my story now and I'm gonna
tell it a certain way I like to stay
true to the story the person is trying
to tell so I like to find
point where we come together before I
even touched the script and start making
those changes that I suggested before
because obviously it's their story right
it's not like I'm being hired as a
writer which is the difference from a
script doctor uh I'm not getting that
writing credit right a script doctor
comes in and they don't do a full
rewrite that just gives you that that
writing credit you kind of remain
anonymous right sort of as a ghost
writer so you need to be you know
talking to your client and analyzing
what they want and that's what you're
trying to tell
and so for a first-time writer who's new
at this has never hired an editor for a
book or anything what should they be
looking for a script doctor consultant
and anything in in the notes of who they
are maybe for new writers I like that
question uh well it's always hard I feel
because writers are looking out there
and there's a million Services right
you're starting to Google like oh who
could read my script you know and you
find so so many resources out there and
a lot of writers obviously first start
you know with their peers which is it's
good it's you know with hopefully other
writers not just your friend who doesn't
really know how to read your script but
you start getting notes like that but
once you're serious about it you know
you've written a couple of drafts and
you really want to take it to the next
level I say that a script consultant is
what you want and I always like to say
that I prefer people go to script
consultant with a name and not just you
know sending it to to maybe a service
that just sends your script to an
anonymous person in the sense that you
know who's reading it you know they have
credits they have a background they have
the experience obviously sometimes in
contests you get you know the free
feedback and that's great but if you're
really paying just for the feedback I
think that you want to know that the
person who's reading it it's someone
with credentials and not maybe just the
intern that's interning for the contest
I'm not diminishing the notes that they
can give they can be great notes but
obviously you also get what you pay for
so if you're going with a script
consultant I like to look for a name you
know I myself when I write I also send
my work out there I work mostly these
days as a script consultant or doctor
but when I do some writing I do like to
send it out because you're always too
close obviously to your own material to
see and getting those notes is always
incredibly beneficial